every one another day on lockdown hair
is getting a little out of control
because you know don't have to leave the
house so I have to read start with why
again I haven't read it in like 8 years
because I'm gonna update it to make a
10th anniversary edition but I was
thinking this is a great opportunity for
us to do something together for all of
us to do something together so I'm gonna
start a little book club here their
requirements you have to have at least
one other person you're going to read
the book with this is not just about
reading it alone I want as many people
as possible to form their own little
book clubs that they can do virtually
obviously we're at home if you're with
at home with family and we're gonna read
a section a week and then come together
on YouTube live and I'm happy to answer
any and every question well any question
that that your book club may have for me
about start with why so I've posted all
the dates below we're gonna do every
single week for six weeks because
there's six sections in the book at 3
p.m. Eastern Time
and if you have questions after you guys
meet submit them to book club at Simon
setting calm and then I will go to
youtube live so I think it's youtube.com
slash simon Sinek and i will take all
the questions and answer them for 45
minutes or an hour every week so pull
together book club gives us all
something to do something to read
together I have to read it so I figured
I'd invite everybody to read start with
why with me I will see you at the first
book club
remember it's something we have to do
with somebody that's the whole idea it's
not just about reading the book it's
reading the book with others take care
of yourself take care of others and I'll
see you real soon
[Music]